هذه الصور ايضا المتداوله
للشرطه البريطانيه التي تلقي القبضه في
بحسب هذه الصوره على على المشتبه به في
هذا الحادث الامني الذي ادى الى مقتل
ثلاثه اشخاص ينتجهم الى هذه الصوره
متداوله مشاهدين لعناصر من الشرطه
البريطانيه اثناء القائها القبض على
المشتبه به في هذا الحادث الامني في
النوتنهام البريطانيه التي تقول الشرطه
البريطانيه فيها ان التحقيقات لا تزال في
مراحلها الاولى وانها تتعامل مع ثلاثه
حوادث امنيه متزامنه في مدينه نوتنهام منذ
الرابعه فجرا تقول ايضا الشرطه بريطانيه
ان هذا الشخص المعتقل الذي نتابع صور
اعتقاله على هذه المشاهد المتداوله يبلغ
من العمر واحدا 31 عاما واكد الشرطه
البريطانيه ايضا ان فريق التحقيق لا يزال
يعمل في موقع الحادث لمعرفه ما جرى في
نوتنهام